foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Agatha Christie's the mouse trap
in my opinion
second-rate murder mystery
not that I've seen it you understand but
it's a whodunit scene one you've seen
them all
you know the drill an interminable
prologue in which all the key players
are introduced you get a sense of the
world they inhabit and then the most
unlikable character gets bumped off
There's Been a Murder
cue the entrance of a world weary
Detective comes in and pokes his nose
around
talks to Witnesses takes a couple of
wrong turns and then gathers all the
suspects in the drawing room points the
finger at the least likely chump because
of the way the guy I don't know
Kaiser's shoelaces
you're an accomplice to murder and so we
ask you to remember that it is
tell the soul outside of this theater
who done it
but what do I know the LIE means they
just lap it up the play is a Smash Hit
not to mention a cash cow right there is
the milk Maiden Chief Petula Spencer
[Music]
[Music]
this lavish Affair is a party to
celebrate the 100th performance
no wonder film producer John Wolf wants
to turn the play into a major Motion
Picture here he is now in the arms of
his slightly paranoid wife since the
death is close at hand
it's probably just a draft
this is where I come in Leo copernix the
name Big Shot Hollywood director hired
to make the film adaptation marginally
less boring than the play and
easiest said than done when the writer
is a giant pompous ass Mervin cochinarus
I say here are the tools am I haven't
really thought about it to be honest in
fact what happened here
sort of a bit of an accident backstage
sure he's educated and he knows a lot of
ten dollar words but it's like he's
never seen a film before let alone try
to write one oh
yeah
no one important
um
you know at times you do rather overdo
the temperamental Neapolitan it's a nice
jacket
[Music]
say
why don't you scare me up a real drink
will you get
like a pint of Rye or bourbon a motor
oil if you have to
yeah hop to it now huh in England that
actually counts as good service I was
stationed here during the war and if
anything the locals are more uptight now
than when they had the luftwaffe
overhead nothing
the deadline I thought so too but then
our esteemed director tore up the
screenplay and told me to start all over
again he's of the opinion that a modern
audience will walk out in protest if
they're not served at least one violent
death in the opening frames suffice to
say we are no longer on speaking terms
Merv
London's most sensitive writer
that was The Mousetrap huh did they
catch the guy who did it I will not
stand here and be insulted
I guess he's gonna go over there and be
insulted
ah what passes for glamor in these Parks
Sheila Sim and Dickie Attenborough
Kid Likes the sound of his own voice
even money he makes a speech I suppose I
have to say a few words not too many
when have I ever remember
Darlings your rivers are kind I'd like
to ask you all to raise a metaphorical
bat to the old Pavilion The Mousetrap is
a hundred not out cheers
tell you what else is a hundred knot out
katula's mother
the old Coo's just crazy about Seafood
they just brought out more langoustines
[Music]
now I'm not one to tell Tales out of
school but the girls over here they go
wild for an American accent and the
promise of a pair of nylons
but the husbands right I think it's time
someone taught you a lesson they're not
so easily won over it's only fair to
warn you that I learned to box in the
area yeah well I learned to play a plane
in Gleason's gym
all of which explains in an admittedly
roundabout fashion how I come to be in
the theater's backstage area in need of
a change of clothes
hello
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I guess I should have seen this coming
it's always the most unlikable character
gets bumped off
it's a whodunit you've seen one
you've seen them all
[Music]
[Applause]